you look at my weirdly shaped boobs I
think wearing right now shows you what
we know about fashion basics you know
are we into fashion obviously yeah look
at us we know like the tears of like
clothes and like how much they should
cost hopefully I think if I find one
thing that fits me I buy it in ten
colors look at it it's just a box pretty
soft look at the way it's sort of I
don't know what you're getting it it's a
little sheer I feel like that's like a
forever 21 shirt I'm gonna go $29.99
that's a $25 shirt I think it's $10
$12.99 80 bucks
cuz it's too good for me it is too good
for me and all that causes 15.99
[ __ ] 1490 that's a steal beautiful it
basically just sells long underwear that
you're supposed to wear around which I
don't hate look at this stitching it's
giving me a bit of a Euro vibe this is
the shittiest reversible shirt of all
time for both sides look like the inside
of the shirt I don't like this some
detail I'd wear this in the nineteen
fifties going to go chop some wood what
these are all exact evidence clothes
yeah this is something a Kevin said
where there's two think it could be a
couple more ribs down 35
that's enough dollars pretty much 29 and
a half it's a trash shirt made out of
garbage fabric I paid $2 for it bet you
$50 $55 Tonya didn't make this so who
gives a [ __ ] that's a deep V you know
who's the king of the deep fees American
Apparel it doesn't quite fit right this
is a tea that you throw on to paint your
porch but it's cute there's something
very bold about the deepness of this V
Freddie will say 14 and I will say 5
just on the off-chance that is that 1997
12 bucks $50 390 from forever
yeah new it one wash will will
disintegrate
the sleeves against off look at the
[ __ ] sleeves a cap sleeve I'm dead oh
did they finish this does that mean by
Kleenex
if I was lady I'd wear this at first I
was like it's so thin but I'm like oh
it's kind of luxurious yeah it's more so
like thin but like that on purpose
this wear on my body you could see well
all my bits
I think it's $85 I'm gonna say 65 65
1554 60 if this costs more than $8 then
this is highway robbery how the hell did
you know that oh my god
I knew is gonna be expensive I don't
think I got any of these right do I not
know that much about t-shirts you know
what I want to put this [ __ ] thing on
how I put this why see what $85 feels
like you know it's one of those things
where like this might be the kind of
basic that'll last forever and in that
case maybe it's worth it I've changed my
mind I've never found so curious I mean
you were all willing to pay a little bit
more for quality but if it's a white
t-shirt who gives a [ __ ] you're gonna
spill coffee on it in five minutes so
just people out there that are buying
these shirts stop
quick imagine just seeing me in Ralph's
like taking cover areas like this it's
smelling a page if you want to buy Kanye
West's $120 a PC t-shirt by all means
and if that's what you want to do
totally do it
it should not have cap sleeves yeah
there's mine and there's another one you
got both of them I only talked to $85
plan now
this shirt is powerful